okay y'all real quick super spill so you
either sip if you don't want to answer
the question you spill tell us the truth
who's the most famous person in your
phone
come on Matt I might be Ben Ben's pretty
famous
well it's actually his wife
his wife is way more famous
what was the last silly thing you did
when you had one too many beers
I would say talk politics yeah that's
that's stupid it's just a terrible idea
who was the last person that texted you
oh my husband oh that's yeah I can spell
the bees with that yeah so I'm on a a
really nerdy
group text that is all about the game
Wordle and and it's sister games quartal
and octortle and so every day
we fill these three things out and we
send each other our scores so
we'll learn it
Jason Bateman left the group
um we gotta do like two Chatty Cathy
yeah it was just like enough of this so
he he left we call it the nerdle league
because we just nerd out and send each
other oh my God
congratulations Avatar 2 has just made
such an enormous enormous Splash did
that come out yeah
[Laughter]
a little sensitivity here man well
Bernie told me that maybe you had you've
turned down the opportunity to be a part
of this franchise that's the dumbest
thing an actor ever did in the history
of acting she's
Four movie
each made over two billion dollars I've
probably done like 50 movies I've never
been in a movie that made one billion
dollars
yeah yeah there's Will Hunting they're
School Ties
That movie made like eight cents
yeah girls eat your hearts out gotta ask
him have you had a chance to have a beer
with one of your famous past characters
that you've portrayed who would you
choose to crack open a cold one with and
laugh yeah I'd probably go with uh
Private Ryan
ah all right someone from that
generation I feel like I could probably
learn something about more about that
three two one action if you could have
dinner with anyone who would it be in
their new commercial for Stella Artois
Zoe and Matt are drinking beer and
breaking bread with Ludacris we were
exclusively on set of the ad which also
helps raise money for water.org and this
year it's it's called let's do dinner
and the idea is just it's dinner party
dinner party and you couldn't do dinner
without safe clean water and so uh it's
just kind of a reminder that these some
of these things that I think we take for
granted I mean you all know a thing or
two about having busy schedules so how
hard is it to get the family around the
dinner table that's always hard because
we're living in an over everything kind
of world where you're overworked you're
overtired you're over committed
um but but family time and bonding is
really really important it's good to get
tips from
from parents that have like some years
ahead of me and and um
I am a lot older and you you know you
and your wife like you've traveled
you've but you've always stayed to
together as a family and my husband and
I have been practicing that same Mantra
that it doesn't matter where we are as
long as we're always together and the
kids they were born into a traveling
circus so there's another we can't
really change that and Mom and Dad are
the lead acts well have four daughters
so when it comes down to sitting sitting
down and having a dinner these are
things that I don't miss you know you
build your schedule around them and the
pound profit schedule is jam-packed he's
on tour with Janet Jackson in his new
movie fast 10 is in theaters now it's
showtime here we go all right I have a
little fast 10 sipper spill game I'd
like to play with it let's play it it
was the worst dinner date so at least
they're wrong because you don't know if
she's trying to kill you or if she's uh
if she's trying to befriend you again
who's the better cook you or Vin Diesel
Vin Diesel they're saying a lot about
myself because I don't think either one
of us do the cooking in our households
all right who has been your favorite
franchise cameo in the past I'd say
cardi B and maybe we'll see her in the
franchise again it'd be great we didn't
have to sip at all because there's
nothing that you can ask me that I'm not
going to answer we'll start sipping now
cheers buddy cheers to you
foreign